pour michel polac le compte à rebours a
commencé et à quelques jours de la mise
à feu de droit de réponse l'émission qui
marque son grand retour à la télévision
michel polac un peu perdus s'aventure
dans ce qui sera bientôt le décor de
droite réponse c'est sûr que ça va être
terminé à temps
on a toujours peur c'est comme les
général de théâtre la veille rien n'est
prêt à 3 heures du matin c'est là que
l'affolement général puis le rideau se
lève et puis tout est en place
là on est dans le décor bah là on est
dans ce qui va être le décor c'est à
dire la f1 il y aura des projets au mail
de suivre les projecteurs voilà sans
suite noté les micros et puis là il y
aura les les banques est on fire est les
gens soient si là ce mois ci la 3ci là
bas et puis moi je serais quelque part
fait là-bas et puis je m'adresserai aux
gens qui sont autour là puis je me
lèverai de temps en temps pour aller
parler à l'un ou à l'autre
et puis un acquis ce livre a au fond qui
voudra demandé la parole et puis les
caméras vont se promener dans ce décor
en fait voilà comment se présentera le
décor une fois terminée une sorte de
bistrot ou plutôt deux clubs à l'anglais
un lieu imaginaire si vous voulez
d'ailleurs on a tellement d'imagination
que gilles va séance après une
découverte comme ça sur un décors en
trompe l'oeil qui fait un petit peu
théâtre italien né de la renaissance et
est à son compte on puisse rêver la
réalité maintenant avec le vidéographe
un étrange appareil électronique qui
permet de faire en direct des dessins à
la télévision et les déci data sur les
ondes un petit rôle un peu
ainsi dieu c'était parfois ils pourront
faire des petites bulles et les petits
textes sur l'écran pendant que les gens
parlent si les gens sont trop bavard ou
les ennuis ou qui sont pas d'accord ils
interviendront dans le débat mais avec
des dessins au lieu de la parole les
plus grands photographes auront
également leur mot à dire dans cette
émission si s'organisera autour de trois
thèmes cinéma littérature est faite
société
[Musique]
et 20h30 sais pas c'est pas une heure
casse-cou pense qu'à cette heure là
c'était plutôt on avait l'habitude veut
l'entendre sheila johnny hallyday eddy
mitchell
c'est très casse cou mais remarque eddy
mitchell sheila ils viendront dans
l'émission bavarder nous on passera des
bouts de disques pour discuter de leurs
chansons mais c'est vrai que c'est des
changements d'habitude mais après tout
les gens qui avaient envie de type
d'émission que nous allons faire là il
fait toujours attendre dix heures du
soir
maintenant ce sera eux qui vont avoir un
peu des privilèges chacun son tour c'est
normal les gens de la chanson
retrouveront leur tour plus tard faut
faire d'alternance alors l'émission
s'appelle droit de réponse ça veut dire
que tout le monde va être un petit peu
égratignée il y aura des répercussions
des retombées oui il y aura peut-être
déjà égratignée je veux dire le problème
c'est pas des tonnes méchant
systématiquement c'est dire franchement
ce qu'on pense alors d'où la nécessité
un droit de réponse si quelqu'un dit
quelque chose de discutable il faut
toujours que la réponse soit possible
même au téléphone avec as bp s'il le
faut voyez il y aura svp sur le plateau
et il y aura la puce et la semaine
suivante devenir aussi avec nous
discuter dire non je suis pas d'accord
est ce qu'on a dit la semaine dernière